where are the men to marry but then we
don't ask the question well where are
the whys and in all honesty guys I think
there's more husbands than wives you
know the average guy's stronger than the
average woman so the average woman is
going to get a bit of protection I'm not
saying a lot but better than living
alone right
um provisioning the average guy still
makes more than the average woman in his
lifetime
um chicks that monetize Beauty are an
exception but the average guy still does
make more so even though you might have
to work he still offers more
provisioning
um but do women typically offer
femininity do women typically have
Homemaker skills and you know I don't
even completely blame women for this
because we everyone's a victim of the
time